this is a production of Cornell
University
so today we're gonna talk about reading
selection evaluation for cold climate
conditions you're gonna learn about what
is all happening in North Dakota State
University most people don't realize
what we are actually doing there in a
state that doesn't have trace so back in
2017 I gave a similar talk talk to the
Magnolia society in Sweden and there was
people there from Norway Sweden from
Finland there all talk about how
horrible their climate was so I quickly
changed my title to my climate is worse
and that was the Thema at that
conference but so this was back in
January 2019 so we had a minus 13 temp
this was two weeks before the polar
vortex hit so this is a pretty average
day in January for us you can see how
happy I am with that our program started
back in 1954 it's a really long lasting
program it was started by the gentlemen
there in the middle Dale Herman and he
is emeritus so I took over in his
position when he retired in 2010 I
started in 2011 you're gonna see some
pictures of our research farm in here
just a moment but we actually did name
and dedicate a majority of the Arboretum
in his name and this is the only time I
can ever think of where somebody hasn't
given a million dollars or died he gave
no money and he's still alive
but we did maintain Arboretum after him
because of the amount of work that went
into it and it has given me the chance
to stand on his shoulders which you'll
see in just a moment the main purpose of
our program is diversity we know the
issues with ash with Elm spruce pine you
know all of the disease and insect
issues that we're having we need to
increase diversity and that's what our
program is all about
we need well-adapted winter hardy pest
resistant trees for the northern climate
I always tell people I'm the northern
trial for the US but I'm also the
southern trial for Canada Canada has
gotten rid of a lot of their kind of
USDA components so all of the research
now is being done in the industry and so
it's kind of unfortunate so we have a
really strong hold in Canada our
material goes up there quite a
a lot of the commercial nursery
cultivars are not suited for a zone 3 in
a zone 4 so we really have to come up
with new material two main goals of the
program one is to evaluate unreleased
materials so everything that's out there
you know we work with the nurseries when
you read the tag and it says its own
poor Hardy it's generally because it's
gone through our program and so we give
the thumbs-up thumbs-down on the
materials and then the other goal is to
actually select and breed new material
for the nursery trade as Brandon said we
have 58 releases that have gone into the
nursery trade not all of them are viable
but quite a few are and what's nice is
that yes we are cold but they have a
wider use than just a zone 3 in a zone 4
so where am I North Dakota is probably
one of the two states that people
normally have never visited and so
that's what it comes to North Dakota and
South Dakota so here's our great big
world that we live in so we'll zoom in
there's me and so if you ever want to
come out and visit don't visit in the
wintertime come out in the summer it's
quite beautiful but we're sitting on a
Fargo this is what we're kind of known
for is the movie Fargo even though was
not filmed in Fargo but if you do visit
Fargo at the visitor center we actually
have the original wood chipper anyway so
here's our state and so our evaluation
sites Fargo you can see is on the far
right side I can actually throw a stone
into Minnesota we're right on the Red
River and the Red River Valley is an
ancient glaciated lake it was one of the
largest Great Lakes larger than all the
Great Lakes combined and it one day it
also decided to drain away our topsoil
ranges from about 50 to 100 feet deep
but it's a heavy clay and the rest of
the state then is a sandy loam soil and
so that's why we came up with the
Absaroka site because this is actually
on the beach edge I can dig down 5 feet
and hit gravel and so we'll talk a
little bit more about that but across
the state we have these other red sites
these are other sites that we're doing
evaluate
that one that I'm actually really
excited about is this Langdon Sykes the
true zone 3 3 B and the only issue I
have to worry about is not deer but
moose they'll actually come in and eat
the young trace now we had an anomaly we
had the coldest winter we've had in the
last 25 years was this past winter so
the traditional map that we see is here
on the left so the upper part of North
Dakota is a zone 3 3 B rest North Dakota
is primarily a 4a we actually hit
primarily a zone 3 and 3a even parts of
zone 2 and so it was a really brutal
brutal winter we're located on the 47
degrees north latitude and this will
come into play in just a moment of where
and how we select our materials that's a
really important aspect because I use
the köppen Geiger climate classification
system and so we're in a DFB and that
means we have a warm summer humid
continental climate coldest month
average below zero degrees Celsius all
months with average temperatures below
22 degrees C and at least four months
averaging above 10 degrees C and no
significant precipitation difference
between seasons and so that plays that
into then our world zones we match up
our DFB to other areas one area where we
get a lot of material from is Harbin
China Harbin China is almost a complete
match to Argo North Dakota or North
Dakota when I first started at NDSU my
predecessor Dale Herman was still around
and he came up to my office first week I
was there and he goes Todd there's one
thing I never did when I was working
here at NDSU I deal with that you just
go to Siberia to select plants and I
said I quit I'm like are you serious but
it matches obviously our zonal climate
so the plants do well there they're
gonna do well for us so just to give you
an idea you know obviously way too much
here but if we look at the bottom here
last frost free date is May 10th first
frost free day is September 25th because
year much earlier than that our average
growing days are 130
very very short season here our average
temperature generally is minus 17 in
January January 29 or 2019 we got down
to minus 36 and that's the actual real
temp and it was an extended length of
time it wasn't just like one day and our
Langdon station actually fared a little
bit better they got down to minus thirty
eight I say better because I'm one of
the few people in the United States that
wishes for a true minus 40 temp because
it really screens out my material I want
to see what's going to be super hearty
so the arboretum itself as we saw is
located in abstract North Dakota and we
have evaluated over 200 different genrih
over 3,000 different species and
cultivars and over 9000 accessions have
come through the system obviously not
all of them are alive my job is to kill
plants so we do not have that extensive
of a collection but we do it is the
largest woody plant ornamental
collection in all of North Dakota but
even the northern Great Plains we only
rival the Minnesota Landscape Arboretum
but we don't do weddings we have a total
of 80 acres about 60 of that is in my
control so if you google Absaroka North
Dakota this is what you'll get so here
you can see Fargo Fargo is actually a
fairly large sized community now Fargo
Moorhead is about two hundred thousand
people people don't think about that but
that's about a third of the population
in North Dakota and then here this red
pin that is our research station so it's
outside of the Red River Valley if you
go in you can see our little island of
green among the sea of agronomy and then
if you would come in this is what you
would first see as you come inside so we
have a lot of display gardens and a lot
of plant trials so this is a aerial view
the center is the daily Herman Research
Arboretum about 35 to 40 acres and
everything's planted in true Arboretum
fashion so it's just random and it's all
alphabetical
and it starts with a B's goes all the
way to zelkova zelkova is not Hardy but
I plant one every year so I've a busy so
I have an annual zelkova and because of
course everybody plants alphabetically
right yes of course the other areas are
where we do our plant trials which
you'll see here in just a moment where
we line material out whether it's a germ
plasm we've collected or its material
that we're testing for a nursery for a
trial but again about 55 to 60 acres is
what we control out of the whole arm
there is the horticultural farm is the
whole thing so we do have hops growing
out here so there's hops back I think
that here now there is grapes which have
gone quite a bit this area is now
certified organic so there's a lot of
other things going on with this farm as
well but for the most part I control the
whole farm for the most part the nice
thing about our woody plant Improvement
Program is that it is obviously ideal
for the northern climate conditions but
it also matches really well for the
urban site as well because we know that
urban soils are typically compacted
they're dry they're high pH North Dakota
is one of the driest states where the
eighth driest in the nation and so a
majority of what then we screen for is
drought tolerant we also screen for pH
tolerance because our soil at the
research farm ranges from about an 8 to
at 8.2 and that's typical for most North
Dakota soils is that we're greater than
8 so some evaluations that we do
germplasm source wise you know we're
getting material from foreign domestic
seed sources we go on exploration trips
within the region within the nation we
do some exchanges internationally as
well that gets more and more difficult
every year but we also work with some of
the exchanges that happen like with
Longwood and the Atlantic Atlanta
Botanic Garden and we're working with
these larger entities that have ways
into some of these countries we are
looking at plant breeding I'm going to
talk a little bit about plant breeding
today that was one
that my predecessor Dale Herman was not
able to do in the time frame because he
had to collect all this material that
farm that you saw used to be a wheat
farm and there was nothing there when he
first started the first planting was in
1974 and so he had a way for everything
to mature so he was doing seedling
selections no breeding improvement my
background is in in vitro tissue culture
I worked under John priest for my
masters in PhD with woody tissue culture
and so we look at so much color
variation and real rescue mutagenesis
and also genetic engineering we work
with nursery partners Bailey's Isley J
Frank Schmid JN plant selection spring
meadow I mean all the major nurseries in
the US and Canada as well we're working
very closely with them Isley came out
with a Jack Frost series of hybrid
Korean and Japanese maples we tested
them out twice for them not Hardy which
was good and we'll talk about in a
minute but here they have ice dragon an
Arctic Jade Northwind lasted for a while
but if I died for us as well this is
Northwind you can see the Sun scald
damage and the die back this tree is
completely dead now so this again what
we do is we kill plants this was one I
wanted to try the Arctic Jade into my
yard to give a little bit more
protection so this is here on the Left
this is actually spring it's dead except
for the very base so I thought hey I can
turn it into a bonsai plants and some
beautiful bonsai now so if you want a
good bones I saw series but we'd work
very close again with industry partners
we have a big industry block that we are
planting out and we get the JFS trial
pack that they send out everywhere again
we kill all their plants but we work
again very closely with a lot of
different nurseries plant improvement
methods that were involved in is
breeding seed source and seed lot
variation and then selections by
obviously landscape observations where
most year cultivars come from when it
comes to woody plants is just finding
that something unique it's already
growing out there
so some traditional breeding I get
really into magnolias and we'll talk a
little bit about magnolias here in a
minute you wouldn't think that we could
do magnolias in North Dakota but we can
and so here I'm playing bumblebee so our
primary breeding that we're working with
is Elm lilac magnolias in Maple we're
dabbling in some other areas as well but
that's the primary ones and we'll talk
about why so maple wise again this is
where I'm standing on the shoulders of
Dale Harmon and so he has selected all
of these material that's super Hardy and
then we can now take it to the next
level so here we have northern spotlight
Korean maple by far the hardiest of the
Korean maples because even the seedling
selection that you get from Bailey's are
very marginal they die back extensively
for us this is Hardy down to minus 40
one of the problems though with the
Korean maples there's not much variety
there beautiful beautiful fall color but
you don't have any variety there's no
cut leaves
there's no red leaf forms you know
there's there's no none of that variety
that you see in Japanese maple and
that's where Eisley got into the idea of
doing the hybridizing with palmate 'm
and sousou boleyn 'm here then we're
doing the same because now we use our
parent which is Hardy the hardiest and
cross it so we did some initial crosses
and this is what we were getting so a
lot of variety with even purpley forms
green leaf forms red forms cut leave you
know you name it a ton of variation
present with these crosses this is one
of my favorites comes out with this
beautiful red it does fade into a darker
green but then gets an amazing red fall
color as well so these now we're testing
for hardiness we do now should be
showing you some controlled freezer
studies and then also planting them out
into the field to kill them hopefully
these won't die we obviously have soul
induced chlorosis that's very typical
with high pH so I teach our woody plant
identification course these are our
golden maples so any of the Freeman
maples don't do well for us one is
because the hardiness issues especially
like with autumn play
but also obviously with the background
of the red and even the silver are not
Hardy for us and not pH tolerant silver
maple here on the left you would think
that wow we actually can kill a silver
maple yes we can kill silver maple in
our soils so this is actually a tree
that's close to our main plant science
building that no longer is there the one
on the left and then also red maple
again
showing extreme iron chlorosis and for
some reason every time we build a new
building at NDSU the architect always
puts in a red maple which I'm really
excited because it allows me to teach
red maple for about five years
and it will die but then they usually
plant a new one so we've had some
ongoing ones so it's nice
obviously the hardiness issues this was
just a study that was done with Autumn
Blaze in Siena Glen showing that DBH had
a really important factor on dieback but
they just don't do well for us we with
our screening though is that we have
found silver and Red's that do well and
so now I can take this and we're gonna
make and we are making our own 3min
maples so with the silver maple Blair
McKay's seedless silver cloud skin
arrived be be wary I do very well pH
tolerant really Hardy same thing with
rubrum autumn spire fall grandeur fall
grandeurs and NDSU release as you can
see here on the right nice upright form
to it the issue that comes in is that
nobody is producing this red maple which
is Hardy to a zone 3b and pH tolerance
8.2 but nobody's producing it because in
order for a nursery to produce a new
cultivar they have to drop something and
if you look at like J Frank Schmidt who
they're the ones that are known for
producing the the shade trees they
already have 25 of their own red maples
so with that said then is that we are
going out and using this introduction
and we're breeding with it with the
silver maples to make our own freedom
angles
and so here we have our seedlings we
work with several different nurseries
again we're limited with some space we
have some conservation nurseries in
North Dakota and South Dakota that we
work with so we line them out then we go
through and we can select what we want
and then they sell the rest as
conservation plants so it's a win-win
for for both of us so then we end up
with these really nice Hardy Freeman
maples that are doing well we're seeing
a lot of see a lot of variation with the
hardiness and with color we're again
selecting on our site with that high pH
soil here we have a bicolor that's doing
very well and again this is just seed
source so this is what dr. Herman was
doing was selecting more just seed
source variation Red Bud you wouldn't
think that Red Bud would do well in
North Dakota but again her seed source
evaluation we have a source from Kansas
that would die back to the snow line
every year not too much of a surprise
but then we have a Minnesota source that
does exceptionally well and so this past
year J Frank Schmidt released it
northern Herald Red Bud beautiful Red
Bud but still only Hardy to a 4 B we
have another strain that's actually
harder to probably even a 3b actually no
it's Hardy to 3 B but the leaf quality
isn't as nice but we're gonna use it as
a parent and actually breed with red
buds we have an agreement right now with
Bailey's cuz Bailey's bought like
there's breeding program and there you
actually using our red but the northern
Herald to increase the hardiness of a
lot of his material but we decide that
we're going to do it as well again by
landscape observations you know again
letting the seedling variation of the
city foresters they've done a great job
of getting a lot of seedling material so
we actually drive around talents that's
what you do you drive around towns
looking for something different you know
upright Baroque we're really trying to
get more uprights into the boulevards so
there's less pruning healthier for the
tree more cost-effective for the city as
well so always just looking for you know
something that is just different but
letting nature do its thing here
one that is amazing September flares
sugar maple this is one of our releases
hopefully Canada is going to be getting
more excited about this but it's day
length dependent not temperature
dependent on fall color it started for
us in North Dakota it starts coloring
September 15th weather we have an early
fall or a late fall and so what's nice
that we're always looking for material
that shuts down early that's so
important that is a good indicator that
it's going to be Hardy if it shuts down
early one of the big issues with a lot
of the cultivars that are out there they
they're from a southern source they just
keep growing and growing and growing and
growing they never shut down and that's
very detrimental for us so this shuts
down it starts coloring if you look in
the background in this picture nothing
else in the landscape is colouring and
this sugar maple always colors in the
middle of September and what's nice pH
tolerant to 1/8 so how long does it take
to release a tree yes I've got this
September flare you know it's like oh I
want one I'm gonna get one the Morton
Arboretum put out with their Chicagoland
grows introduction this nice kind of
idea of how long does it take and so
they release exclamation London
Planetree and so it gives you an ideas
at the timeframe that we're looking at
is about 15 but 50 years for a plan to
actually be available in the nursery
trade so because we spent all the time
doing the selection work but then we're
also going to be doing propagation we
figure then we make the selection and
then it has go to the nursery the
nursery also then wants to evaluate it
in their production system for X number
of years to make sure it's going to work
whether it's going to go container
whether it's going to go where is it
going to be in the field you know what
are they gonna do and so it really can
take a long time this is one of the
biggest problems that we have is that
we're dealing with multiple generations
you know juvenility periods and woody
plants gonna be anywhere from 5 to 15
years so if we're doing breeding work
you know I'm doing a lot of breeding
work that won't be for me but it'll be
for my successor so here we have that
London plain tree liner grower if you're
out in the Pacific Northwest
you're one either tissue culture cutting
your to outdoor liner bed then lying on
the field established centiliter
root prune develop branching so you know
they're evaluating the plants themselves
for at least five years before they say
yes or no and a lot of times it comes
out to be a no because it just doesn't
work in their production system here
nursery production for small to mid-size
year trees can take upwards to nine
years for them to really see one type of
structure is it working for them for
large trees it can be upwards to 15
years just in the production evaluations
so some recent selections that we have
September Claire is one of our new one
Japanese tree lilac
this is not utility friendly but that's
good we want to sometimes non-utility
friendly compare it to ivory silk which
comes out to be about 20 foot tall ours
is 35 foot it's a nice upright you know
we all know kind of what a Japanese tree
lilac can do they're extremely tolerant
and so this is one that I want on a
Boulevard you can see obviously with
ivory silk it is in a utility friendly
situation and that's good but I don't
want this little blob on my Boulevard if
I don't have utilities because in South
Fargo our utilities underground
I want summer Flair and what's nice that
you can actually watch it grow and again
that's important for nursery releases is
that they have to be able to kick out a
tree within two years or it's not
profitable for them you know they always
keep talking about how we want these
dwarf compact trees but then they won't
grow them because they take too long
this is what I'm really excited about we
mentioned it takes fifteen to fifty
years to release a plant this is our
northern Empress Japanese elm and so it
has inherent dd resistance because of
being a Japanese almond straight
Japanese and we sent this out to
Carleton which is now owned by Bailey's
they wanted to test it because frontier
elm for them did not bare root well and
they were looking for a replacement and
so they tried out our new elm it's much
smaller stature about 28 foot so not a
huge elm by any means which is great
fits in the landscape really well and pH
adaptable
grow into any type of soil and any type
of pH and what's great is also at
seedless so we have not seen any seed on
this at all but it gets burgundy fall
color and not very common for an elm to
get burgundy fall call there especially
one that's Hardy into his own three
frontier gets burgundy
that's not hardy for us and so through
Carleton evaluation took um five years
and it went through all the production
evaluations with glowing thumbs up and
they're actually replacing this with
northern Empress with their before their
frontier so very excited this is kind of
our Cinderella story so this is actually
available next year and super excited
but the original germ plasm was planted
in 1984 and we just released it and I
think 2012 so I do a lot of tissue
culture so we were getting it into
tissue culture you can see how much
Calais Elms typically will throw a lot
of Calais and so I don't want to go into
great detail with some of the studies
but we wanted to use an antioxidant
compound PCI be the the P chloro phenoxy
ISO butyric acid which is a kind of an
antioxidant our antioxidant compound and
what it does is that it actually binds
to the side of the oxygen receptor so it
won't produce all the callus and so we
did a salt screening as well as using
the PCI B and we were then called
treated after six weeks we kind of
wanted to see what would happen and we
found that 10 micromolar of the PCI B we
significantly reduce the amount of Cala
seen and it gave us a really high
propagule number so we're very excited
about that but the need added bonus the
what I really want to say here is that
we were able to cross borders into
Canada with it there's quite a few
provinces in Canada that's de d free and
the only way I can get a plant into them
them is through tissue culture and I had
a fight with the Canadian government to
really get them to accept cultures to go
across that border but in the end I want
and so now we have a tissue culture
facility Agra forest in Canada that is
actually producing liners of this as
well
this is cinnamon curls dwarf Korean
birch it's a castaño birch it's not a
very well-known birch it's a Korean
birch my predecessor he loved big trees
and when I first came on site and
started learning our germplasm I was
like wow I really like this tree because
it's dwarf and he's like Todd I don't
know why you like dwarf trees like
because the rest of the world does
but anyway so here's me standing by and
it tops out about 9 foot where well I've
got another picture in a moment but now
Eisley nursery has it in cuttings here
you can see on the right those are
rooted cuttings in the summer of 2019 in
2018 they were able to get tissue
culture liners and get them to be about
two foot in one year so very excited
hopefully they're gonna do very well
because they have a beautiful
exfoliating bark for us Fox Valley the
little king river birch just doesn't
perform it's get sclerotic it's not
Hardy this is a great replacement
it's drought tolerant its pH tolerant as
well
beautiful beautiful selection and what's
nice is you can't really see well in
here but it's already starting even
within that first year getting the
exfoliating bark lava burst buck I
always say this is the buck I think
you've turned on its side you know buck
eye is typically very very wide but
we're I'm really trying to push more
uprights to get a better fit into a
Boulevard so this is an upright buck I
no problem with leaf scorch beautiful
fall color it actually produces very
little seed I wish it produce no seed
but it produces very little seed and
they're generally quite small but look
at that structure of that all upright
just beautiful beautiful tree this is
what it looks like after a second year
planting this is the first year planting
this is my technicians wife he says you
know the height of it is the average
sized wife but anyway but what's nice
about this is that it bundles well it
digs well you don't get them breakage
again those things you have to consider
when you're evaluating something because
how is it going to come out of the
nursery as well this is one of our
newest one attention birch again not a
very common one
birch is very strong for us we have
decode a pinnacle birch but that
actually get bore as well this one's
actually improvement of Dakota pinnacle
extremely drought tolerant beautiful
form beautiful high quality foliage and
again we have it in tissue culture and
ready to go for release we also have an
azalea that we screen for pH tolerance
the University of Minnesota has the
northern light series they're Hardy
marginal for us but not pH tolerant so
here we have this beautiful fire flare
orange that does extremely well with our
high pH and our heavy soils as well so
we have that in tissue culture and
hopefully we'll be getting that out here
soon
some future releases source it a phylum
japonicum Katsura tree very excited
about this one because this is marginal
in the Twin Cities and this is Hardy to
zone 3 B acer trump Kadem hybrids this
is a big hybrid now the trunk a dome
with Titan oi T's JFS has come out with
all of these different ones they're not
Hardy they've all died for us but we
actually had truncated next to some of
our plant neue T's that we got from
Norway extremely Hardy we weren't ever
gonna plan to release a Norway maple but
then we found the diversity within these
so all these nice beautiful fall colors
and so far they've been Hardy all the
way down to minus 36 this is what I'm
really excited about standard leaf of
these hybrids are here on the left this
has this miniature little crinkle leaf
and so it has a really neat ornamental
quality to it kind of like a little bit
about like crispy lettuce look but the
new growth comes out like this so all of
that new growth every year would be that
bright red crinkly look so super excited
about that we also have a purple leaf
form as well and ends up kind of that
purple red in the fall color so some
research obviously I mentioned tissue
culture we do a lot of tissue culture we
do a lot of grafting here we actually
messed up some Oaks so we've done a lot
of oak rootstock compatibility trials we
took prairie pioneer dwarf Chinquapin
oak which is actually pH
and we put it on bicolor which is not on
the left and guess what it becomes
chlorotic we put it on macrocarpa on the
right and no problem so it shows that
really that roof stock is so important
when it comes to pH tolerance and we
have we cannot grow white oak well we
put white oak on macro carbon it is
beautifully for us so we actually get a
nice fall coloring oak a lot of cutting
propagation Acer tri florrum this is one
that's impossible to propagate we have a
release called orange aglow we have
about five in the accession so I took
one of the sibs and I cut it down to the
ground so that way I can rejuvenate get
the new shoots and do some et relation
and we're actually getting some roots on
trifle so really excited about that then
hopefully we can actually start getting
clonal try florrum magnolias oh my
goodness that's a whole nother talk and
we've got 15 minutes but I just kind of
want to go through that because again
most people don't realize that we can do
magnolias and is one of our big breeding
programs we do a lot of shoot for scene
to get things into tissue culture so
here's I'm just introducing magnolias
into culture we do a lot of freeze tests
we have the programmable freezers and it
just gives us a better controlled
environment and so here we were looking
at saucer magnolias and then again this
is where I stand on the shoulders of
Dale he released a Magnolia spring
welcome spring welcomed magnolias Hardy
down to about minus 38 we lost some
flowers this year so we were kind of on
that marginal end but here you can see
which is not too surprising that we had
60% damage at minus 36 of the flower
buds with foster Magnolia that makes
sense
whereas our spring welcome we were right
around about that 15 to 18 percent
flower bug damage so really showing that
the freeze trials can work for us to do
some initial screening of hardiness so
how do I get into this crazy world of
magnolias actually with Green Bay
Botanic Garden there is a hybridize er
there this is actually his house that I
mapped out but Dennis ledvina
right here is one of the leading and
unfortunately he passed away
quite a few years ago now but he really
got into pushing Magnolias up into the
zone 5 and so I'm utilizing his material
across it with what we have and pushing
up even further
now one thing for those either grad
students interested in breeding be
careful because you can get really
involved and really excited about
something so the very first year I did
it I made a hundred and fifty crosses
and then I did two hundred crosses the
next year and that equated to about like
five thousand seedlings it's too much
and then I had this aha moment one year
I was actually sitting next to on the
plane to another board member of the
Magnolia Society International he said
Todd what are you doing with breeding I
said I don't know I'm like crossing
everything that's dumb because you
already have a hearty white all you need
is a hearty pink and a hearty yellow
because why spend all this time crossing
everything so you really do need to be
focused and look at that so that was
kind of my aha moment so this again is
just showing all the seeds you can see
where we are making all these crazy
crosses but in ultimately what I'm
focusing on is hardiness looking at
overall plant size looking for some
dwarf compacts flower color shade
because all we have Hardy for us are
white and that's why I want to increase
the colors and get better forms this is
our spring welcome Magnolia it's a
lobner I cross between Kobus and salata
does really really well we've done quite
a bit of bridal trials here's yellow
lantern this looks beautiful actually
had to borrow a picture from the
Missouri Botanical our because it only
flowers for us but a lot of snow lie and
here the next picture you can see also
where it's stem dies back like pretty
much every year we do get flower buds
but they never make it through the
winter even Leonard Nestle you can see
where the flowers are is below snow line
royal star which is kind of the standard
is only flowering below snow line so you
can see here some flowers and some
flowers so there's a lot of room for
improvement
so how do we overcome Bud hardiness
again is utilizing our material and then
focusing on these acuminata hybrids
because the akuma nada is really really
Hardy and it has those yellows but also
the hybrids that Dennis Lebanon it has
the Reds as well so we found another one
that's straight stellata in Bismarck
North Dakota that's been served that
survived down to minus 42 so this is one
that's not released into the trades this
is my own private breeding parent just
beautiful Magnolia but again just
straight white this is my Subaru that we
actually filled with all these plants
from the Green Bay Botanic Garden and
took back to North Dakota planting them
out most of them died so here's my
students that were planting them all
they look beautiful you know in the
summertime unfortunately you know a lot
of things have died so again this is
kind of beyond but you know cotton candy
beautiful plant but we really wanted to
show that our breeding efforts were
worth it it finally died in 2017 Rose
Marie died in 2017 this is one of the
most beautiful hybrid magnolias out
there cylindrical completely dead
Angelica is dying here's the flower buds
obviously not worth it that's all power
of magnolias Red Baron has actually
shown to be Hardy but no flower buds
form Jeanie is one of the best because
it's compact get this amazing flower
color but it's not Hardy which is good
but we're actually using Jeannie to
breed with to get a really nice magenta
color these are all of our 2018 that
have died
here's ones that are alive actually 2019
oh pretty much all of these are dead
except for Red Baron looking at the
different bloom times extending really
focusing again on the Akuma nada hybrids
again like I said this is much more in
depth with really what we need but again
focusing on these smaller forms to Sun
sprite is amazing it's about 12 foot by
1 foot and this is the yellow that I'm
hoping to get Hardy because this is just
fit in the landscape so beautifully
so if you ever want to get into Magnolia
breeding it's actually really easy it's
one of the most easy plants to breed
with because all of the parks are so
readily accessible the stamens are there
the carpals are there we do have
obviously Teeples with the female
portion
oh it's receptive when all the styles
are curling out when they curl back up
they're no longer receptive and at that
point then the pollen will D hiss so you
can remove all of the stamens and then
process your pollen and you can do this
even on the same plant because you'll
have some that are receptive some that
are no longer receptive and so you can
collect pollen pretty much at any time
here I've got the stamens that you pull
off so you can see here this is our
female portion now that's no longer
receptive stamens have all been removed
you put it on a piece of paper let it
sit out overnight they D hiss they
release all the pollen and you're good
to go so whenever I go collect pollen
this is my hotel room I always at the
foot that Do Not Disturb sign on because
I figure they think that I'm like
Breaking Bad like I don't know what I'm
doing in there enjoy I don't want people
to come into my room but again same
thing here now is that we're using this
geni pollen that we collect and then
cross it into what we have now we did a
lot of field breeding this is actually
my son my youngest son he is one of the
best hybridize errs everything he
hybridizes always works but one of the
big problems is that cold temps in the
spring limits pollen tube development
and so field breeding is really
difficult and so again here we are on
the field it's also more dangerous the
older I get the less I want to go up on
a ladder so I send my son up there but
again using our spring welcome Magnolia
we do a lot of crossing but then what
happens so here's a great example April
26 2017 we got down to minus 4 and
here's our Magnolia sinful blue and we
got down to minus 4 there's no pollen
tubes developing them and so we've now
gone into breeding everything indoors so
I've got everything potted we force
flowers we collect pollen etc so
everything I do is inside
and my grad student on the left my son
again here on the right I let him do all
the work because he's amazing
always looking then just get that fruit
to develop then we collect all the seed
we actually go out and collect acuminata
seed for all of our root stocks so again
if my son out there to collect the seeds
for me then we process them grow them
all out it's nice plugs to create root
stocks we do a lot of grafting as well
to get everything scaled up and number
wise here's one that was exciting this
is actually not with one of our hearty
ones but I'm hoping in the future be
able to cross it in the variegated
first-love by Red Baron just a beautiful
beautiful plant now phenotype II this is
one thing I discovered several years ago
it's like phenotype beans always
difficult and how do we deal with it you
know I know a lot of you have had a deal
with the color charts and they're very
subjective you know what I consider to
be a red somebody else who might not
consider to be the same red and so
several years ago at a SHS I was
actually thinking it might be from
somebody from Cornell that was doing it
it was in a fruit reading where they
were actually evaluating Apple skins for
the color and color immature is
expensive but not very subjective and so
you you know most people use the CR 400
but it's very expensive and so what I
found and what they were presented a SHS
that they were using the NYX Pro color
sensor $150 and it just it links up to
your smartphone and you can actually
scan then the colors know the Knicks Pro
is designed for interior designers so
they have all the palettes for paints so
all of the Sherman Williams and
everything so you can set it on anything
in this room and it will tell you what
Sherman paint will match that color so
what we did then is use the next Pro and
we had developed our own database and it
tells you how to do that and so here I'm
phenotype bean of Magnolia people and it
will scan the color it'll tell me all my
RGB everything that I need to know but
then using the RHS color palette it will
actually tell me what is the closest
matches and what I find is that I take
an average reading you know three to
five different readings in an area and
it's almost always the same and when I
go back then to the color palette and I
match it up I'm like yeah that's exactly
what I would have chose so it really
cuts down on time it cuts down on the
subjectivity of trying to find those
colors but this is what you have to do
I had an undergrad scan all 812 pallets
to fit the database but then once it's
in then it works we do a little bit of
genetic engineering not a lot
obviously ornamentals we can't do a
release a GMO into the landscape but one
of the big problems is that the
juvenility phase with woody plants how
do we overcome that well we can do
serial grafting to get them to flower
sooner and so one thing I found is that
the fast-track breeding that was used by
the USDA with Klum's we can actually
utilize that in ornamentals and what
that is and again that's a whole nother
talk if you're not familiar with
fast-track breeding highly recommend you
look it up but what they did is they
inserted a early continuing flowering
gene into plum and it turns the tree
into a vine and it then sequentially
sequentially flowers all along the notes
so you'll have fruit development at the
base and it'll still be flowering at the
tip and so it constantly flowers and it
flowers within the first year so it
allows you to do some breeding now for
me and then you can do back crossing to
remove that but then again you're still
stuck in that generation of the back
cross what we're utilizing it for wants
you is to create route stocks that have
this early continually flowering because
they show that in Apple they can have
these ECF transgenic root stocks they
put a sign on to it and that sign will
flower in the first year so that's
translocated not the obviously the gene
but the characteristics so if we can do
that with magnolia I don't have to wait
because our spring
welcome Magnolia from seed the flower
was 13 years I can't wait that long but
if I can then develop these seedlings
and then graft them onto these
transgenic root stocks I can screen them
within the first year for flower color
yes oh okay
so what we saw is that we actually are
getting somatic embryos directly for me
using pic lorem so very excited so I
actually I just want to end on this I
know I'm out of time but what is the
hardest part of woody plant improvement
and the easy part is obtaining germ
plasm propagating cuttings planting
evaluating breeding and slightly that's
easy part the hard part is naming your
relief how do you come up with a name
and I go into the whole royalties and
etc but you know we've got this new
plant and this is where I land is
emerald beacon that tension birds I
wanted a name that name it emerald
beacon but I couldn't because of Michael
Dirr owning beacon oak
he owns the term beacon so I couldn't
use it so we had to change it to a
player so anyway so with that in the end
we really all we want is happy trees
right we do have quite a bit information
online if you ever want to get more
contact me just let me know
with that we'll take any questions
any questions for dr. West basis for
this extreme cold parties good question
and and one of the things that we look
for is that early shutdown is that the
big indicator of extreme hardiness you
know certain species have the ability to
work with artists like cornice obviously
with a lot of the species we're just
looking for that more of that early
shutdown and that really is a big
indicator for us for the cold hardiness
see any ID on no I don't know yeah but
it's doing exceptionally well in that
high of a pH and it always has because
it's been under evaluation since 1974
and it's always performed beautifully so
we finally got around to releasing it
well yeah
it handles that high pH and why yeah
because it really shouldn't and and
again that's that just that seedling
variation just for some reason that
one's doing well because the others did
not
we've we've evaluated a lot of azalea's
for hardiness and for pH this is the
only one that's doing well I stopped for
you crabapple trees I do not we do
crabapple evaluations but I don't do any
any improvement work with crabapple it's
that's a hard hard world to get into
there's so much out there and so many
people that are way ahead of us yeah yes
once I get available yes I will I will
send you some yeah once we get the
culture is going and we route them all
out yeah some work on this losing battle
and many that I
that really nice oh yeah it's a total
losing battle this one's amazing this
has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu